la salut c'est monsieur noël aujourd'hui
on va parler de la ligier j'aurais pu
vous parler des quelques temps du lgv 35
qui a été annoncé par la marque et pas
particulièrement parler là par contre je
vais parler d'un modèle qui pourrait
arriver très très très prochainement
c'est le ngv 48 pour le coup pour être
vraiment intéressant donc si vous en
parler
avant toute chose on va regarder ce que
j'ai reçus parce que là ya pas mal de
nouveaux trucs qui sont arrivés
[Musique]
petitpas tâches techniques
j'ai mon micro qui s'est déchargé plus
batterie dont j'ai présenté quelques
produits qui vont arriver sur la chaîne
malheureusement ehpad sont donc je
voulais montrer rapidement il ya ces
produits hyper cool de rhinochill qu'on
va essayer si quelques temps qu'ils ont
des objectifs que vous pouvez rajouter
sur vocaux créneau shield ça c'est
plutôt cool
du coup on va avoir du fichage lors du
grand temps lors du super grand temps
aujourd'hui macro voisin l'adaptateur
pour mettre sur l'iphone disent donc ça
c'est cool deuxième truc qu'on va
protester on reste toujours dans les
optiques pour les smartphones chez sans
marque ça ça nous vient directement de
californie c'est un objectif grand-angle
pour iphone 10 on ira tester aussi d'ici
quelques jours
morse il intéressant puis troisième
produit qui arrive et qui l'a plutôt
cool pour le regarder c'est un casque de
gamer sans fil on va tester on va voir
s'il est intéressant et puis au final
fera un petit débrief là-dessus langolen
parce qu'on a loupé désolé la
technologie elle est bien aidé m des
côtes elles nous plantes ont un petit
peu dans le dur
est ce que je veux dire donc je voulais
vous parler du lgv 40
c'est ce que je vous disais chez elle
j'ai eu pas mal de produits intéressants
il ya eu le v30 l'année dernière car
plus bas je m'en parlait lui avec un
écran oled avec une belle qualité photo
de l'audio vraiment bien avec un
partenariat avec bang & olufsen
le lg c'est ce qui arrivé cette année le
sgv 35 et là on arrive avec un lgv 40
qui pourraient être annoncées dès cet
été pour une sortie au mois de novembre
alors qu'est ce que ce lgv 40
intéressant en réalité ce qui est
vraiment à la 5 ce produit situé
directement du point de vue des capteurs
photo il pourrait avoir pas moins de
cinq capteurs photos en tout c'est à
dire 3 capteur à l'arrière et deux
capteurs à l'avant alors au niveau des
trois capteurs à l'arrière vous aurez
d'abord un capteur plus standard pour
faire de la photographie et de la vidéo
je dirais classique un deuxième avec un
grand angle ce qu'on a l'habitude de
retrouver chez lg et un troisième un
téléobjectif permettrait d'avoir du vrai
zoom optique ça ça pourrait super
couleurs pour le troisième on marche un
peu sur des oeufs
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que me permettrait de travailler avec un
éphèbe ok ça ça pourrait être vraiment
intéressant et à l'avant vous auriez de
capteurs qui vous permettrait d'avoir
probablement on peut imaginer un
grand-angle
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on aura
vraiment un effet boké hyper naturel ça
sera cool et en plus ce que ça va
pouvoir apporter c'est un espèce de
faith and lobe qu'heidi inflation de
l'ocs équivalent du fei saïdi qui nous
permettraient gras
aux deux caméras de reconnaître des
visages en trois dimensions des pouvoirs
le déverrouiller avec un système un peu
plus sécurisé que facebook
bon reste à voir si c'est vraiment hyper
secure ça on le verra d'ici quelques
temps donc restez connectés abonnez-vous
on ne sait pas actuellement s'il aura un
écran oled ou un écran lcd
je pense que sur un modèle haut de gamme
chez elle j'ai vu que lg qui fabrique
des écrans oled
on devrait retrouver à priori un écran
oled ça me paraît complètement normal
non plus que les écrans oled sont
vraiment démocratiser sur les
smartphones haut de gamme
si elle gérait avec un smartphone haut
de gamme sans écran oled tout en sachant
qui fabrique des écrans oled
c'est un peu bizarre autre point sur
lequel on est sûr c'est retrouver une
qualité audio irréprochable
lg a toujours eu une excellente qualité
audio l'artois un partenariat avec bang
& olufsen cette année à mon avis ils ne
referont pas la règle et niveau audio ça
te renvoyer du bois ce smartphone
devrait avoir également une encoche
c'est la grande mode des encoches on l'a
vu sur le social feu dont on est sûr les
fans disent on l'a retrouvé sur
énormément de smartphones cette année
sauf au pot et vivo qui commence un
petit peu je dirais à 1 6 3 une solution
alternative mais lever 42 rien à voir sa
fameuse encoches une encoche
désactivable un peu comme ça pour
trouver sur le wan +6 vous avez la
possibilité de ne pas l'afficher ou de
l'affiché au choix d'un nom existe c'est
plutôt pas mal
côté performances on devrait avoir un
qualcomm snapdragon 845 qui est
aujourd'hui si qualcomm la puce la plus
performante donc de ce point de vue là
on devrait pas être déçu non plus et un
smartphone qui a selon irène blast un
petit nom de code qui s'appelle storne
les infos que j'ai cité vient du site
android police qui ont récupéré
petite info à droite à gauche star des
personnes qui sont proches de l'âge j'ai
donc des infos qui paraît quand même
vraiment relativement fiable donc tout
ça en règle sur connecter parce qu'on va
le regarder ensemble l'année dernière on
a pu voir le lg d'être ensemble à l'ifa
à mon avis ils vont présenter ce
smartphone cet été donc ans de pouvoir
la boire entre nos mains directement fin
août début septembre à l'ifa donc rester
connecté parce que je vais y aller
et comme ça on croit voir ça ensemble
disloque moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que ce smartphone pourrait vous
intéresser à ce que vous avez déjà mis
des produits et le gnc g7 v35 v30 enfin
va y en a plein énormément de produits
dans la gamme m des modèles antérieurs
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez
merci à vous d'être là toujours plus
nombreux toujours plus nombreux mark et
moi toutes vos questions suggestions
interrogations tout ce que vous voulez
directement bas et puis il restait
qualité parce que d'abord il ya plein de
produits testés ya plein de nouvelles
choses qui arrivent latex ne s'arrête
jamais et on va bientôt partir en voyage
restez connectés à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]